Jason this drum thing you're using which
is the size I said of an iPad is this it
sounds to me like you could do a whole
concert just with that little piece of
equipment you if you really pushed yeah
and I notice you take your drumstick and
you hit the side of that thing when
you're playing ambient mics in Hague you
could listen to that field this guy is a
real drummer I'm serious
is that because like your dad you hit
the drums hard is that why the sound is
a certain awesome right it's a technique
there's quite a lot that about my father
they got kind of he was the heavy hitter
he was this if you watched the 69 the
Albert Hall
he owns the stick really fire in his
hand so it's he's not getting a big a
lot of throw it's just the technique of
where he hit the drum and how he's
shooting the drums but my dad he could
play his kit it sounds like his kit then
he would play my toy kit at home and it
still sounded like him before your dad
died did he teach you how to play drums
was he your teacher he was the guy that
would and funny I got to work with Bill
Collins a few years ago right the
beginning of us working together and I
told him a funny story because Phil
loved my dad and he said he saw him
before he was in Zeppelin and he said I
said well when you'd released Duke and
the tourney onigen came out and you just
beat my dad in the Melody Maker drum
awards poll so he got me he got me to
learn turn it on again by Genesis it's a
12 year old kid right so I'm 12 and he's
on the drum kit he's put it on the
jukebox and didn't think Tintin
so I'm playing along with it so I do
about three times do it again do it
again about third time you got it you
guys I don't know what the big fuss is
about my 12 year old boy could play that
song you know what was great I got you
Robert Plant a while ago and I always
wanted to ask him this I love that
Kennedy Center Honor it's Jimmy Page
Robert Plant there stands there sitting
next to each other and you you Jason
came out with heart and Anna Nancy
Wilson and you were playing what song
did you do stay away yeah
did stay away and Robert Plant is
sitting there crying and I was like GI
if I ever get to interview Robert Plant
I gotta ask him why he was crying and
and he said I was crying because I was
watching Jason you know my you know yeah
these buddies kid what it was what his
boy was playing drums yes Jason
yes I thought all those years later you
know it was just one ridiculous loss he
was really thinking about you and and
and the performance was great they did a
great job with that tire you see that
was the that I surprised them that's why
there was such a reaction they didn't
know I was gonna be there oh they were
really cause usually I can't keep my
mouth shut right so I literally yet that
when I walked out and Robert said to me
after he goes I literally just said to
Jimmy man cuz well their family was
there or their kids were there he said
we should have invited Jason to
experience this he goes then on you walk
with your bowler hat you got him because
the guy wasn't the guy was in tears
yeah and that's what he was crying about
there was gonna be a Zeppelin tour there
was rumors of it after that but you went
up to Robert you said hey we gonna do a
Zeppelin tour and he said to you no
[ __ ] way because not no insult to you
he said at the time it was literally a
few months after and you know you in my
mind people were going it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
so I was like um can I just get this out
of the way I said is he gonna happen he
went well listen no no disrespect to you
because what you know of your father is
amazing he goes but what he said all
those years ago we would be idiotic to
continue on and not stand with what we
said we've done this we did the show we
don't have to do it again let's just
leave it at that
you know your father was such a huge
part in round you know Robert Plant's
for but seems like just on that one
story he seems like a very loving guy
like you like he the way he handled you
yeah it was very delicate he's the one
who told you he came to your house to
tell you your father was dead right I
mean he was yeah hon yeah and with his
wife yeah Maureen yep they were pals
they were best buddies
Oh